was sagt man ja menschen man wird dann
wenig salbungsvoll und sagt ich bin
glücklich und stolz daniel brühl bei
klicks und begrüßen zu dürfen den
schauspieler der inzwischen auch
international berühmt geworden ist mit
produktionen wie krabat goodbye lenin
inglorious bastards also eine
international schon richtige nummer und
ihn treffe ich anlässlich des osborne
kurzfilmfestivals da sitzt er in der
jury thema dieses jahr der stier in mir
darüber werde ich mit ihm reden und
natürlich über eure nutzer fragen wie
immer kreativ sein video frage online
stellen und das war das wird noch mal
genau info text lesen also gesamt an